der chirurg sma bruno weiß stammt aus
jordanien
hier im klinikum vest in recklinghausen
arbeiten rund 40 ärzte ausländischer
herkunft fast ein fünftel der
belegschaft
ob man deutscher oder ein auge aus dem
ausland dieser hat sich für mich sehr
gut
sam hat jordanien vor einem jahr
verlassen um sich hier fortzubilden
die kollegen sind froh über die hoch
qualifizierte verstärkung denn in
recklinghausen herrscht wie vielerorts
in deutschland akuter ärztemangel die
aktien teile von der sprache aber nicht
die worte
deswegen die alte leute manchmal
verstehen nicht deswegen muss ich immer
wiederholen
doch was wenn ärzte wegen mangelnder
sprachkenntnisse fehler machen wie sorgt
die krankenhausleitung für die
sicherheit ihrer patienten kollegen die
noch sprachschwierigkeiten haben in der
regel bei kritischen situationen wo die
sprache eine besondere bedeutung hat
von nativ deutsch sprechenden kollegen
begleitet werden so dass sichergestellt
ist dass es da keine schwierigkeiten
gibt
im bildungszentrum von recklinghausen
lernt der jordanier jeden samstag
freiwillig deutsch für ärzte gesetzlich
vorgeschrieben ist dieser
fachspezifische deutschkurs nicht nur in
wenigen bundesländern müssen
ausländische ärzte erweiterte
sprachkenntnisse nachweisen
doch das reicht bei weitem nicht
einmal tatsächlich zwei sätze die sehr
sehr gleich sind aber sich doch im
detail entscheidend unterscheiden weil
der op gibt es folgende risiken und bei
der op gibt es folgende komplikationen
in rollenspielen üben die ärzte dialoge
mit den patienten wie zum beispiel ein
aufklärungsgespräch vor einer operation
der sprachunterricht ist so praxisnah
wie möglich um später nicht
verständnisse zwischen arzt und patient
auszuschließen
nach der theorie kommt die praxis
besonderer teil des deutschkurses ist
das individuelle sprach coaching
regelmäßig begleitet der lehrer den arzt
zu gesprächen mit patienten natürlich
noch der chirurg möchte in deutschland
bleiben auch dank der großen
unterstützung die er hier erfährt ich
fühle mich wie ein kleines familie mit
dem patienten
ich habe niemals ich mich gefühlt dass
sie aus dem ausland gekommen bin ich
hätte keine probleme mit dem patienten
oder kollegen
trotz meiner sprache und auch privat hat
sam bald eine eigene kleine familie in
wenigen tagen kommt sein erstes kind auf
die welt
in recklinghausen